605. it's talking about time to talk
about the coronavirus are you looking
for those n95 masks well the federal
government's offering them for free but
it's taking a while to get here that's
right i feel like we've been talking
about it for so long first shipments are
still arriving though here in the valley
a total of 400 million n95 masks being
distributed nationwide in the coming
weeks hector mejia joining us live
hector lots of people want to know where
can you find these free masks
that's true good morning to you guys
well as soon as they arrive they'll be
available at local pharmacies and local
community health centers but only select
ones are offering the free n95 masks
this walgreens at tropicana and sandhill
for example is one of them and a company
spokesperson told me while some local
stores have received the n95 masks
they're still arriving and it's a
process that could take days perhaps
several weeks and the white house is
providing up to three free n95 masks per
adult the goal is to distribute a total
of 400 million it's the largest
deployment of ppe in u.s history
according to the us department of health
and human services and so far over a
hundred million have been shipped out
all across the country from the national
stockpile you might remember just last
month the cdc updated the mass guidance
and said hey go ahead and wear the most
protective mask you can find and the
n95s are better than the cloth masks you
can find a list of the type of n95s
being distributed by checking out the
cdc's website and one thing to note you
do not need to show your id you do not
need to show an insurance card and
walgreens also for example they have a
list on their website listing the local
stores here that will be handing out the
n95s that is if they do have them in
stock reporting live hector mejia live
local now